now be honest with me you've probably
laughed when your favorite streamer has
lost their [ __ ] over getting stream
sniped we're gonna talk about why this
is that gigantic problem for a lot of
streamers but it's also really funny and
nobody knows that more than twitches
biggest star T foo who actually managed
to recently confront a fortnight hacker
on stream in a discord call before we
get into the story about T foo I need to
tell you about the award show that we'll
be hosting on January 15th we put like
six months into work into it there's
gonna be a bomb-ass trophy and I really
hope you'll watch it so in case you've
been living under a rock a budding is a
form of hacking where a player uses
software to well have perfect game
combined embodying with stream sniping
which is where somebody watches your
stream to get an unfair advantage and
then kill you and you have two of the
biggest [ __ ] headaches that streamers
deal with on a day to day basis
ttv did [ __ ] shoe saver and at this
point t food dealing with a body and
stream sniping has basically become a
part of his brand him complaining every
single day on stream about [ __ ] 12
year olds with god-like game well it's
just a part of the entertainment at this
point he's been running these things
called t fault scrims for a while now
and they're basically custom scrimps but
he also has a dedicated discord server
for it where he invites subscribers and
anybody else he deems worthy to scrim
against him now he started these for a
whole bunch of reasons one of which was
he wanted a better competitive
environment to play in but he was also
looking to get away from a lot of the
grief that he experienced in pubs as a
big-name streamer this has become a big
part of competitive fortnight it allows
pro players to practice for land events
it allows new players to cut their teeth
and it just provides a more competitive
experience for everybody involved 1:12
you won he's DS logo gun you got the
Chickasha maybe but even in these custom
events that he created to get away from
these issues stream snipers and aimbot
errs have still managed to invade his
streams oh my god i stopped [ __ ]
anybody to disguise as far as baiting
this to kids he hates one inside the
dory here on the side everybody oh he's
he's hacking Zacky oh we got a Riku this
is a body dude yeah actually think about
that for a second it's one thing to
aimbot these guys in pubs but in order
to do that in Tipu scrims you have to do
so much work first you have to get
invited to a discord channel which
either means getting a personal invite
from t foo or subscribing to cloak see
72 hours or a bunch of other streamers
then you have to hope that you're online
at the same time he is and then you have
to manage to get an invite to scrim
against him and then you actually choose
to cheat against twitches biggest star I
mean think about how much work that is
just to get a [ __ ] reaction into
somebody and here's the [ __ ] up part
this happens every single night like
whenever you tune in to watch it's
probably happening you tune in he warms
up and then the next few hours are him
getting headshots yelling about stream
snipers and
welp just trying to [ __ ] win a match
bro you can't make this [ __ ] up bro you
really can't you can't make this [ __ ] up
the most unlucky player to ever live but
on January 3rd tifu manage to confront
one of the aim Potter's that's been
invading multiple defaults crimps and
how it starts out like you might think
chick it strange pretty quickly are you
playing T fault or what did yeah I just
want to scream with you guys is that
fine
yeah yeah okay so intense training on
Kovacs early hey they party like anybody
I get it fun yeah the game is ded yo do
you have my stream open so yeah t Funes
do a partner scoped invite the guy to
scrims and then he accepts and like I
get it it's his big chance to take a
shot at T food it's a trolls [ __ ]
dream but like maybe not a good idea
and then throughout this conversation
yeah there's something about a lawn
mower scoped sounds like a [ __ ]
transformer and then oh yeah this dude
threatens to docks t food let me talk to
your parents
bring them on the mic and I hear it
worked no wonder it probably explains
for why you're getting away with doing
dumbass [ __ ] on the Internet
could you just call him like he did like
her yes no that was a Miss whoever that
was and just know there's the docks
coming very soon and I'm not even joking
woah was I mean now you might be asking
yourself why am I making such a big deal
about T Fuu being pissed about aimbot
errs and stream snipers well think of it
this way in League of Legends or csgo
for example if your simple or double if
you don't have to worry about these
problems your literal job is to win
gigantic tournaments not be popular to
bring this all back to a fortnight the
competitive environment
not where you're gonna make a name for
yourself that's what streaming's for and
so with that in mind
imagine you're someone like T foo or
Nick Marx you wake up every day you go
to work
and then you hope that some
twelve-year-old doesn't just try to ruin
your day and outside of reporting the
player there's literally nothing you can
do about it epic has introduced
anti-cheat software but we all know that
that is just a band-aid slapped on a
much larger wound so if your Tipu in
this situation you're kind of stuck I
mean if you freaked out on stream over
being stream sniped you're giving the
trolls exactly what they want because I
would hear of loot in the kid a dog
every game you [ __ ] ban this dude
that's literally anybody in my [ __ ]
custom game but if you take the abuse or
hell ignore it for as long as possible
they're just gonna continue to harass
you until eventually you break and freak
out again giving them exactly what they
want it's like riding a ferris wheel
that never stops slows down and [ __ ]
people are throwing stuff at you the
entire time it's why looking back on the
face Jarvis situation from November epic
games came down so hard on him in the
first place it's not just because he was
cheating or breaking epics tos it was
because he was teaching other kids that
hey cheating is cool
yep that's uh that's broken that's
broken mate I don't miss a shot I don't
miss a shot Froyo we cracked and well
for tonight is probably the biggest
example of these issues happening in
real time it's by far not the only one
back when disguise toast was on his
hearthstone grind he had to deal with
stream snipers all the time and kripp
made a whole youtube video dedicated to
stream sniping guilds [ __ ] up other
people's matches they play an arena all
day until they get really good decks and
they wait until I get a deck that's a
week to it so if they get like a really
good tempo rope oh no wait until I play
priest that doesn't have much early game
and then on top of that they'll know my
hand they'll know my deck they know all
my answers and I'm expected to actually
do well against these
that's pretty hard to do okay and
remember in games like hearthstone
seeing your opponent's hand ruins the
entire game and in Rainbow six siege
cheating has become a gigantic problem
with dudes like in Tarot and kickstart
weeding out about the fact that
something needs to change and look
there's always gonna be a debate as to
whether stream sniping is right or wrong
but the fact remains is that if you want
to be a big-time streamer this is
something you're gonna have to deal with
and as far as T foo is concerned well t
food like single-player games what does
that mean what is a tier zero of game
hey I play a [ __ ] ton of switch games
alright leave me alone
I can't win I can't win
I cannot win you guys are [ __ ]
killing me here